he was born into poverty but john hume
delivered what money couldn't buy
peace in northern ireland engaging in
secret talks with jerry adams
was the political gamble of his life he
was singularly against the ira
let's be clear about that unto his great
credit
that when the news broke about a meeting
with me
and he was the victim of a a tsunami of
abuse
and of vilification that he stuck with
it
over time he persuaded the irish
government that the gun could be taken
out of politics
and when he brought the british
government on board it was the beginning
of a peace process that would end with
the good friday agreement
john hume genuinely was a political
titan
i mean his contribution to peace in
northern ireland was extraordinary i
don't think we would ever
have really got the peace process going
and
implemented if he hadn't been there
offering help and advice
his reaching out to his unionist
neighbours had paid off
and in 1998 john hume and david trimble
were awarded the nobel prize for peace i
want to see ireland
as an example to men and women
everywhere
of what can be achieved by living for
ideals
rather than fighting or dying for them
bloody sunday when british soldiers shot
14 people dead in his native london
dairy had a profound impact on john hume
committed to the pursuit of irish unity
by entirely peaceful means
he co-founded the sdlp and won
international acclaim for his
peacemaking
but his heart was never far from home
john hume guided this city through some
of its darkest
days and the people here never forgot
that especially when he later found
himself
living with dementia they'd often meet
him walking alongside the river
and journey with him to ensure he
arrived home safely
john dined in the white house he spoke
in europe he spoke in french in the
european parliament he was
lauded all across the world but he was
never
as happy as when he was in derry
meeting dairy people speaking to dairy
people standing up
for the people of this city no matter
where he went he talked about derry
bill clinton who had become a close
personal friend
described john hume as the martin luther
king of northern ireland
[Music]
the man who refused to give up until his
dream of peace
became reality david blevins sky news
in derry